[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's jeff van gundy from the mother ship
he'll join mark jackson ryan rucco
calling tonight's mabs sons game that's
at 10 eastern on espn the earlier game
the lakers visit the celtics mike breen
doris burke and cassidy hubbard will be
providing the coverage of that as jeff
joins us on the show good morning jeff
how are you today
still makes me laugh every time you say
mother [ __ ]
i'm doing good well
i was uh i was wondering about as a
coach when do you when what's the
earliest you think you can get an
assessment of how good you think your
team is going to be during the season
or how bad i would say
you you don't want to under react nor do
you want to overreact so i think you try
to give yourself a quarter of the season
enter around you know 20 games
um
but now it's so hard dan because
there are so many people that sit games
out for injuries
uh or or for you know personal reasons
that it's it's a lot harder to get a
gauge of
what you have because you never have
your team
when do you think will be a fair
starting point to assess the lakers
well i
think when james gets back and he plays
you know 10 games
and
i also think
uh because
james has been out
people have overlooked kendrick none
being out
kendrick nunn will be a huge addition
to their group
defensive intensity some speed and
quickness which they lack throughout
their roster
so
i think
when james and none get back and you see
what they have and if you see you know
how are they going to play with
westbrook davis
carmelo anthony and james and how they
fit around those four guys
and i would suspect they're probably
gonna stick with anthony davis
for a majority minutes at the five i
think then you're gonna know
you know are they a good team a really
good team or a championship level team
what do you do with the russell
westbrook's style if you want to modify
slow down change
or can you at this stage
no i think you know westbrook
for better for worse
is committed to his
his style of play and
i don't think you're going to change
somebody's strengths at this
uh
you know at this age um
his strengths will remain his strengths
his non-strengths will remain their
non-strengths and i think what you want
to do is maximize
his strengths try to minimize or hide
the non-strengths and i think what's
really interesting
is how they're going to go about okay
when james has the ball or james and
davis are in pick and roll
what what do you want westbrook to do do
you want him to spot up and attack do
you want him to spot up and shoot
because he will be open
that's where teams are going to give
support from defensively and i think
for the lakers they just have to decide
what they think gives them their best
chance and i think
when they get when
westbrook commit even though it leads to
some turnovers to attacking
off of
on the second side when he's on the weak
side
i think he creates some good things and
i think
they need that sort of
um thrust to the basket
would you want to coach him right now
you know what uh dan when i interviewed
for uh the rockets job when he was still
a member of the rockets
and this was in the pandemic
and i wanted to speak to both harden and
westbrook
hardin didn't make himself available
westbrook did
and
i had the best
conversation
uh with a player that i didn't know at
all
uh
when i coached westbrook uh when i
talked to westbrook i should say
he was
um
so forthright in what he thought
how he saw himself
his place in the game i really
appreciated his directness and his
honesty
because sometimes in those situations
it's easier
to if you don't know somebody just be
sort of cliche-ish and
um more passive-aggressive and i i just
i really appreciated
uh i've always appreciated who westbrook
is off the floor he does so so many
remarkable things but in that one
conversation
i had maybe it was like a 45 minute to
an hour conversation
um i just really
appreciated his directness and
um
and he was
i don't want to say appreciative of my
directness but i think he
i think he liked uh direct talk and
straightforwardness so it was a great
conversation and again you don't know
someone until you coach him so it'd be
impossible for me to answer your
question but i think from that
conversation
i would have enjoyed being around him
how do you not take harden not wanting
to talk to you as like do you take it
personally that he doesn't want to talk
to you
well i don't know if he didn't want to
just talk to me i don't know if he
wanted to participate in that okay okay
in the um
in the process maybe he already knew he
wanted out i don't know but um
you know
i i just that's again that's not a knock
on heart and he can do what he wants but
i i just appreciate westbrook's time
and his uh
his forthrightness um very very much
we're talking to jeff van gundy he's
with mark jackson ryan rucco they got
the mavs and the suns coming up tonight
is luca going to play
i would they looked in him as that
doubtful so
i would say not which you know
you came here to see luca and booker and
paul
all the greatness and it's a it's a
bummer when you don't get that but i
thought the mavericks held up well on
wednesday
they just didn't have enough offense
down the stretch
when phoenix turned it up
i think steve kerr one of his toughest
jobs this year coach is trying to come
up with new ways to describe steph
curry's greatness
yeah he should not be able to i think
dan what you should throw down the
gauntlet
he cannot use the same adjective
[Music]
all year so if you start with superb
you've got to come up with something
else for the next game
because i think that would be as
interesting as watching
like i i think people are so
used to now seeing curry
take and make
like
these
impossible three-point shots from
distance
defensive pressure
like that we become like almost numb to
how great
this is this is something
that will
i can easily say will never be
replicated the movement off the ball the
ability to shoot
you know against great defense
be able to shoot on the move off the
dribble like he has
completely revolutionized the game and
we're never going to see something like
this so we better appreciate it well i
wondered and i i sometimes overstate my
love for steph curry just because i i
understand that that range shooting like
that and if you're not necessarily quick
or big or strong can't jump but he he's
he's changed the game how many players
in the history of the sport can you say
have truly changed the game
well you're right just a handful because
there's been
like so many great players
but
see i think curry's a better athlete
than people give him credit for you know
the hand-eye coordination the agility
the balance
the rhythm as you know dan as a great
shooter the rhythm to that shot
to be able to get it up
with the soft touch from that distance
you can't be
anything other than a great athlete to
do that so
um
he has he's changed the game and
a lot of guys try to emulate how he
plays and uh
often times you see just
god awful shots being shot in the nba
because they're shooting steph curry
shots that only
you know
he should be allowed to shoot you know
so not every it's not equal opportunity
to take the shots he takes because
only he can make them
at the efficiency level that he does
you're the head coach i'm gonna give you
steph curry's career everything that's
gone on
kd's career
everything that's gone on and then you
get them the rest of their career as
well who do you want
see
you know like
you're you're like
my wife trying to give me like box me in
and like
like make people hate me like how about
this dan you pick first and i'll take
second and i i don't care who you pick
because i'm going to be really happy
with my pick i never knew you would back
away i mean dwayne wade answered it
who did he take
no you answer and then i'll tell you who
he took
no you're not gonna you're not kidding
me no
i'm not married to you
only my wife can box me in okay i i he
took steph curry
and i took steph curry as well
okay well then to balance it out i'll
take durant because if you guys want
like it's a it's a reasonable like how
can you not want to coach steph curry
think about what steve kerr got he got
him both
like in their prime that should be
illegal i mean i watched durant this
year you know because we've talked so
much about how great curry is but i
watched durant this year when i was a
part of the olympic team i'd never
really been around him i actually been
around him two times in my career
the olympic team when i watched him work
out dan i was like
this guy's a machine
his his work
he didn't need a coach there he knew
exactly what he wanted to do
he he worked at a pace that was
game-like which is unusual a lot of guys
stay out on the court a long time but
don't get a lot accomplished durant was
just the opposite he was 20 25 minutes
full speed
every repetition and it didn't hurt that
the ball always goes in the basket right
so
and then the other time
was when i was coaching the rockets
and stopped me if i told you this but
we had training camp
at the university of texas and it turns
out to be durant's only year in college
so we're down there in early october and
we go to our first practice and it's at
10 o'clock practice we got there at 9. i
have no idea who this kid is on the
floor but he is going through a workout
like
full speed
okay
you know he looks like a talented young
guy i have no idea what his name is
we practice he's there
the whole time
then after we're getting off the court
and milling around before we leave
he comes back on the court and works
again
we come back before our second practice
that day at six
he's on the court
he then watches us practice and then he
comes back on the court again after he
did that the whole week we were there
i'm like this guy
is an absolute machine i learned his
name i mean now i don't know when the
heck his classes were but i know when we
were there
for those seven days
i have never seen a guy work like that
that it was impressive and you know what
whatever how many ever years it is later
17 years later or whatever it is
he was doing the same exact thing in a
shorter amount of time
in on courts in japan and it was
you know he loves the game he's improved
with his passing his his handle and
i mean
literally an impossible guy to guard and
so right now
you know you've got curry you've got
jokic and you got durant and they are
all having
these incredible years
has anybody broached the topic with you
of the an nft
you know the picture thing the nba is
doing where you're holding on to alonzo
morning's leg
and you could sell that
and and people are paying big money for
these nba moments but uh
i don't know what that means what does
that mean like
isn't the picture out there anybody
could have it if they wanted it i don't
know why you'd want it but mclevin
explain nft to coach so the people
involved have exclusive rights and yeah
the picture is out there but you can
have ownership of exclusive rights to it
uh basically you can limit the supply
you're the only one who has the official
jeff van gundy alonzo morning leg photo
oh
well well that's what what a great
moment to try to own
my temporary insanity
that's as stupid as what i proposed the
other day to mark jackson
so think about this makes any business
sense to you dan you're you're a
business guy
i saw that the lakers the staples center
changed their name
to crypto.com right yeah and they got
paid this huge amount
what if i changed my name
legal to crypto.com or some or taco bell
let's say and so mike breen when he
comes on the air says
i'm here this might bring with mark
jackson and taco bell
do you think they would pay me two and a
half million dollars a year
to change my legal name yes
yes let's get it done let's get it
because it like tonight let's say ryan
rucco introduces you know mark mark
jackson and jeff van cripto
yes
or coach crypto yes i'll go like coach
prime like dion sanders coach crypto yes
i i think there's money to be made there
see and i think all broadcasters should
change their name legal name
and then put it on their their legal
name could go on their jacket
because how can the mothership say i
can't put my legal name on on on my
jacket right when they come to an on
camera
i was thinking about that even dan this
is how how lonely you get in the hotel
room
how about you know the um name image and
likeness yeah for um
what if all those players just legally
changed their name
to
you know
at center taco bell
at forward mcdonald's you know
wendy's is your point guard like
and at quarterback arby's
yes what i think that's how if i became
a college coach i'd have all my kids
change their legal names and then you
know change them back when you go to the
nba or or into the real world you know
so
yeah i think i'm on to something better
than the what the lonzo morning
insanity where i look like a fool and i
deserve to be
like
they should have stopped the game right
there and dropped a ring down
and and made me in morning fight and
just have morning just pummel me you
know for my coming on the court did you
ever talk to alonzo morning about that
where you're holding on to him like a
ball and chain
no you know what he was like back in
those times
like
we played the heat four straight years
in the playoffs and they went
to the final game all four years and so
in the in the regular season games we
played four times a year and they were
just like brutal so
you know you developed this like sense
of like dislike i mean my brother was on
the other staff and i'm like i'm not so
keen on him during the weeks we're
playing miami right so
the morning thing happens and and i have
never spoken the morning in my life you
know
um
and so the next year i just was
fortunate enough to be the all-star team
coach
and i'm like dreading having to coach
you know morning in the all-star game
because you know like you know you're
gonna have to like talk to him
a and b
you know
he's going to have to like you're going
to have to say something about being a
like a clown
uh holding on to his leg
and so i was so grateful we were heading
out to media day and i hadn't seen him
yet
and he
came behind me and grabbed me and hugged
me from behind i didn't know who it was
and it was him and he broke the ice and
he was so
um
i don't know what the word would be but
it was just so
nice like about the whole thing where he
you know he could have made me feel even
worse than i already did about what i
did so
i'll be forever grateful for his
kindness
in that moment and then it took me about
after the game it took me about 12
minutes to get back to my anti-heat
have fun tonight there uh crypto and uh
it'll be the mavs and the suns that'll
be at 10 eastern on the mother ship uh
great to talk to you jeff thanks for
joining us
all right dan take care
he's got a lot of downtime on the road
but
yeah jeff van cripto
i like it